friedrich lamar brought the heat during
his halftime performance at super bowl
56 in los angeles the compton rapper
performed his hit songs alright in mad
city
[Applause]
during his set he paid homage to fellow
compton native dr dre who was the
visionary behind the halftime show that
also featured performances from eminem
snoop dogg 50 cent and queen of hip-hop
soul mary j blige to honor the super
producer during his performance kendrick
had this to say about dre's longevity in
the music industry
you forget about dream
35 summons in the making i'm talking nwa
the pulitzer prize winner also had men
surrounding him in black suits with
bleached hair wearing sashes reading
quote dre day
[Music]
and when i wake up i recognize you
looking at me for the paste up this
year's halftime show marked the first
time that hip-hop took center stage
following the performances rapper busta
rhymes gave e.t his thoughts on how
pivotal of a moment this was for black
culture what does it mean to see this
group of folks break through on this
stage i was fortunate enough to be able
to come and witness with one of the
rehearsals
emotional for me
for tears
yeah because but
proud and tears of joy though obviously
primarily what it means to our culture
is everything everything just on an
intergalactic level
beyond earth i think we proved tonight
that hip-hop
is part of the american dna jessie
collins one of the halftime show's
producers explained how this
game-changing production came together
you know this is one of the fastest
first halfs in nfl history and so
we had to make sure that there was
plenty of production value lights in the
stadium huge set
and then just monster hits so how do you
make it with the moving pieces and all
the people popping up and down i mean
just an incredible team i mean that
thing came on and i think less than
eight minutes tonight
the dps team the roc nation team the nfl
everybody just working hard knowing that
we had no choice you had to get that on
i only heard it hits out there tonight
and i thought that was different because
usually artists want to do one or two
songs to advance a cause everybody did
hit absolutely i mean listen i think
that was established from day one
i think
whenever dre and jay sat down and said
these are the artists and these are the
records it was like we're gonna pick the
cream of the crop everyone is in tears
because
you know that you know dre
changed music
go back to nwa he made the world look at
the west coast and what they were saying
and then he has continued to change it
over and over again eminem 50 cent it
goes on and on kendrick snoop it's like
he keeps keeps changing music changing
music for the world these are the
avengers of music all together in one
halftime show this is superstars
[Music]
you